somalia's President says the death toll
has risen to at least a hundred after
two car bombs hit the capital Mogadishu
hundreds more people were injured the
al-Qaeda linked al-shabab extremist
group has claimed responsibility for the
attack
[Applause]
Darrow struck in the heart of the Somali
capital
[Applause]
two cars loaded with explosives tore
through a busy intersection near several
government offices
the Force Blast hit the education
Ministry compound
several minutes later came the second
explosion just as ambulances started to
arrive
The Cloud of smoke shows the power of
the blasts
I was in the area when the first
explosion went off after that I ran away
I saw many dead people but I don't know
the exact number may God have mercy on
the dead people and help the injured
this is the deadliest attack in Somalia
since a truck bombing at the same spot
in 2017 killed more than 500 people
of people gathered outside hospitals to
search for missing loved ones
claiming responsibility for the attack
the al-Qaeda linked al-shabab group
called the education Ministry an enemy
base
that receives support from non-muslim
countries
somalia's president visited the site of
the blast and vowed to continue fighting
the islamists
foreign
we in the Muslim Somali people are at
war with these men
as we speak fighting is going on in many
parts of the country
while the President says government
forces are winning fighters from the
group continue to Stage attacks on
Military government and civilian targets
let's turn to Uma Mahmoud he's a senior
Analyst at the international crisis
group an independent Think Tank working
to prevent Wars and solve conflicts
welcome to DW sir I want to start by
asking how common are such attacks in
somalia's capital Mogadishu
well unfortunately al-shabab shown an
ability to penetrate Mogadishu these
attacks are not that infrequent
um you know it seems every couple months
or so there's some sort of major
incident but this one's particularly
unique given the civilian death toll um
given how close it was to it to a major
road and an intersection and it really
brings back shades of a very significant
attack uh I think as you mentioned in
your segment from five years ago which
had a massive civilian casualties you
know upwards from five six hundred so
it's the most significant attack like
that since then but unfortunately
al-shabab is is quite active in
Mogadishu
the government says it's winning the war
against al-shabab but isn't that claim
difficult to accept when attacks like
this happen and not infrequently
well I mean the government's undertaken
a new offensive against al-shabab in
certain areas of their control
especially in central Somalia and they
have been able to seize a significant
amount of territory in this they do have
a bit of momentum on this side but of
course also about has the ability to
react you know tough questions should be
asked as to if there's so much security
protection within Mogadishu how is the
group still able to to bring in these
types of explosives into the city how is
this able to happen on you know um you
know at least a semi-regular basis so
um I think you'll continue to see these
types of incidents you know both sides
are kind of committed to a war footing
right now so unfortunately more violence
is likely to transpire
let's get some perspective here what's
at the core of the conflict in Somalia
between islamist militias and the
government
well al-shabab will say that the uh the
Somali government is is really a
western-backed government it is
basically installed there by Western
allies and is the secular government and
kind of goes against their version of
sharia and against Islam as a whole they
also have a very particular point of
contention by the fact that there are
foreign troops present on on Somali soil
so they've been fighting this war for
about 15 16 years by now but you know it
seems that you know both sides probably
need to try to figure out a way that yes
I mean they're going to continue
fighting each other but at the end you
know how long can this continue for um
there needs to be other sorts of tracks
and I think
um the dialogues as well as difficult as
that is to imagine right now
a dynamic situation for sure that is a
Oma Mahmoud from the international
crisis group many thanks for your
perspective
thank you